she wrote and stars in the new film good
on paper which is available right now
on netflix one of the funnier comedians
in the world
she is eliza schlesinger back on tour
joining us from the state of alabama
where she's back on tour in the back in
action tour and
joining us right here on the rich eisen
show eliza schlesinger how are you
oh man it is warm here okay i'm great
in that order in that order it's well
yeah weather first
physical comfort first but mentally i'm
doing great okay and then what's the
traffic like if you want to do traffic
and weather together
uh alabama what's traffic
ladies and gentlemen there's a truck but
it seems broken down
a lot of cupcake shops we're doing okay
back in action let's talk about your
tour i mean um
what in the world was it like for
somebody who i imagine
loves the human contact of give and take
and being in front of a live audience
what in the world was it like the last
year and a half
for you we all kind of
we all kind of got it uh this last year
i i did
a uh i called it a comedy tailgate tour
around october you know just wanted to
do a show wanted to perform so people
came out
and they tailgated and they watched the
show you know we do set them up in a
field
so that was cool a little dystopian
little weird but it was still better
than nothing
and then you know it was one of those
things where we'd gone so long without
it even having outdoor
shows it's still like i was like i'll
take it and
it just became normal and so now to get
back out there and be
invited back indoors and i don't feel
like a barn animal
is really nice that is good not being a
barn animal i think i would agree
is something that uh that that is what i
guess that's the goal every day
when you wake up that's the goal to not
feel like a barn animal i agree
so how did you get into stand-up walk me
through how you realized you know what i
i i like making people laugh and i want
to give this a whirl
oh man i had that realization about a
year ago
and i was just like i think this is i'm
gonna make a job out of this because
nobody wants to hear the story
it's so boring it's not true you wound
up on you wound up on tv and you won a
contest and now look at you
kidding me no but you know these last
couple years of really
you know getting the up stand up as
everybody wants to be a stand-up or a
rapper or
an athlete okay and uh to actually
create a career at this you know takes a
billion hours and
going out and doing these tiny shows and
all places and it really you know you
cobble together an experience and
um i'm fortunate to get to do shows for
the uso i love entertaining our troops i
love
doing comedy and weird places i think it
makes you a better comic and
the netflix specials have been a great
tool for you know traveling all over the
world but
at the end of the day i just love the
craft of it and i love
i love unearthing uh all the weird
things that make our society go round so
that's my real passion
all right eliza schlesinger what do you
want to talk about i'll give you the
floor what do you want what do you want
me to ask you
how does that look yeah it's not about
the straws
it's about the emissions and it's about
our consumption of meat no we can talk
about the movie
we can talk about anything that's on the
talking points rich
okay talking points let me see
talking points right here other than the
movie uh okay so
what's your biggest pet peeve then
what's that oh man what's that like give
me a category
okay planes yes planes uh what's your
take on on the armrest
if you're sitting there in the middle of
a of in the middle seat do you get both
armrests
elijah's lessons don't be caught in the
middle that's rule number one
okay rule number two if you're in the
middle you get the arm rest because you
don't have the aisle not that it's that
much more foot room
but you don't have the solace of the
window uh my biggest pet peeve is when i
get on a plane and i say good morning to
the flight attendant and they don't say
it back
because i know they've already like gone
to nashville and back
three times that morning and they hate
everyone but it makes me feel really bad
about myself well
so it's not about you realize it's not
about you it's about it's about their
day right
and you're trying you're but i think
that's nice you're trying to brighten
their day
eliza i'm trying it's if you want to
know what our society will be like in a
post-apocalyptic situation
yes go to an airport it's people just
it's almost like a comedy club like
people lose
all sense of decorum it was like
everybody was raised
by a wolf and people i've seen people
actually eat other people
to get onto no that was just a sabaro
i think i think you're just mistaking it
you know
for the old i don't know and uh what uh
one of the pretzel places that normally
are
i think people have just people have
just forgotten yes exactly one of those
but people have just forgotten how to
behave i mean we're seeing it in
sporting events right now
where people have forgotten how to
actually be around other people
it's not we have forgotten they ever
know did they if you're the kind of
person who would knock out
like a pregnant woman to catch a foul
ball were you ever
like a leader of manners were you ever
doing the right thing
no that's true you're right that stuff
did happen pre-pandemic
where i did yeah like just ripping
ripping the ball out of a kid's hand
just so they could celebrate it
i know i've seen that too oh yeah i
think uh
people are very excited to get back to
although it depends on where you go you
know i just did a string of shows in
orange county and i was like
i live in hollywood it's so great to be
able to go out and and they're all
thinking like we've been out
of the problem whatever
like where are you from yeah just
literally 40 minutes up the road you
know with no traffic
40 minutes the road gets very blue and
that's where i live
right up there eliza schlesinger here on
the rich eisen show
good on paper is that based on something
true that happened to you
what do you got for me yeah that's right
it is okay it's a movie that i wrote i'd
say this movie is two-thirds true we're
calling it a mostly true story for legal
reasons based on a lie
and it is about uh a guy that i met on a
plane
okay um and we became friends okay and
we were friends for about a year and i'd
say we
dated eventually for like three months
and i found out every single thing he
had told me about himself was a lie
and before people get all weird and
judgy these weren't things like i'm a
billionaire and i have a fleet of yachts
these were like
very basic get to know you questions
like what you do
where you're from who you are and uh
this movie is about
if we're calling it a rom-con um it's
about like a
yeah like a meet-cute you meet a guy and
then it's about like something doesn't
seem right
and uh trusting those instincts and then
in the end it's a bit of a once upon a
time in hollywood weird brutal ending
that i made
does it involve a blowtorch is that what
you're saying it involves a blowtorch
it actually does involve a blowtorch a
tiny one because i'm a girl
uh there's a tiny bit of revenge fantasy
for the fun of it but it's all very
grounded when i ask myself if you tried
to kidnap a grown man
would it go well and the answer is no
it'd be very hard okay you're
your last name slices you're not
tarantino is basically what you're
saying
yeah that's that's exactly what i'm
saying okay so
uh does this gentleman who strolls the
planet know
that this film is out about him
from the bottom of my heart i don't know
and i i deeply don't care
because you've moved on you've moved on
this happened in like 2015 i wrote it
takes years to get a movie made
yes i've been married for three years
what if i was married to him that'd be
hilarious
it was just um that's a real twist
ending it was something at the time was
like a super cathartic thing to write
but it really became about the film
and the comedy and the art of it and uh
don't care if he sees it don't care
where this person is
don't even think i wish him well or ill
i just wish nothing
just don't want to think about him well
but you did this whole film about him
and so you know uh you're not even like
wishing a little bit that there's a
gopro like on the top of
you know his television set as he flips
on netflix to watch good on paper
when it's technically okay because then
i think i'd have to reconcile with how
genuinely unattractive this person was
who i did
date and uh i think
the movie becomes about your main
character it's about him as a vehicle
for comedy
um and making a point you know i think
it's so easy when a girl does something
to be like well it's about men and
it's really in the end about her and the
comedy and
a really good cast and giving actors
something funny to do yeah margaret cho
ryan hansen rebecca rittenhouse some
very funny people that you got
involved here that are in this film and
so were you in the middle seat when you
met him on the plane
eliza just time you know it was first
class and so there was no middle seat
okay um there was a window seat and if i
remember this correctly i
got on the plane slept for like the
first three hours then i got up
put on makeup because my boyfriend was
picking me up to get ready and it was
only then that he talked to me
granted i was awake but i've not gotten
out
to put on the makeup i think it would
have been a different story well that
middle seat reference was basically my
attempt at a callback to use a comedy
term
um you know so i guess the callback
would be
had we had a middle seat perhaps i never
would have met him at all well he would
have maybe
shown his true colors with the middle c
because i do believe that people show
their true colors
over just the basic courtesies on things
like that
you know uh i i really do like like if
somebody takes their shoes off on a
plane that's got to be the end of it
end of the conversation on the spot what
if what if what if you have a dad who
takes his shoes off in restaurants what
do we think about that
oh boy are we
already sketcher sliders so they came
right off it wasn't like a lace-up boot
situation so what do you what do you say
dear old dad what happens then what do
you do put your shoes on
public put your shoes on this is
disgusting i'd imagine so
oh gosh yeah that's uh that's that's a
non-starter but you know i guess
family's family you can't do anything
about that
you can't be my dad if you take
back in action tour uh elijah
schlesinger in
alabama on uh today and tomorrow irvine
you're back here in southern california
and more dates and info can be found at
eliza.com
uh i appreciate the time congrats on the
film let's let's talk again
i'd love to have you in person in studio
i i appreciate uh
you know i i like your your your netflix
specials and i
look forward to seeing more from you and
i'd love to have uh more of a
conversation
in the future you guys heard it it was
an invite i'll be there if you invite me
i'm coming
up that's absolutely great you can have
both uh both rest of of the armchair
here because there's only one
eliza slender here on the rich isaac you
bet at eliza on twitter and at eliza's
on
instagram right here on the show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here